Many times we have seen that
glycolysis is a process,
where we start with glucose,
which has six carbon atoms, and breaks it down
up to two pyruvate molecules
each of which has three carbon atoms.
In this process
two ATP molecules are produced in total
and NAD + is reduced to NAD.
We add a hydride anion,
so this is a reduction.
-
Of course, we also produced water
and hydrogen ions.
But the next question is - what happens next?
We can talk about cellular breathing,
it occurs in many organisms.
It happens in your body right now,
so you can produce as many ATP as possible.
That's why we're moving oxygen.
Because oxygen is needed for cellular respiration.
But sometimes there is no oxygen
or I may be an organism that does not use oxygen
or does not perform cellular respiration.
We have already seen an example of this
and that was the lactic acid fermentation.
This is a way to recycle NADN molecules,
they are oxidized again.
They are oxidized and once again converted to NAD +.
This is oxidation,
converting NAD to NAD +.
It happens during fermentation.
In fact, for both types of fermentation,
which we will talk about.
In the lactic acid fermentation we talked about
that pyruvate oxidizes NADH
and thus the pyruvate is converted to lactic acid.
It is used to make yoghurt, sauerkraut,
it is also used in muscles,
when they do not have oxygen.
If you sprint or lift
very, very heavy weights,
you may have lactic-acidic fermentation in your muscles.
But now we will talk about another kind of fermentation,
this is alcoholic fermentation.
Alcohol.
Alcoholic fermentation.
-
When we talk about drinking alcohol,
we are talking about ethanol.
Some also call it ethanol
fermentation.
As you can guess, it's a process,
which is used in the production of alcohol, but also of other things like bread.
It's used pretty much in baking.
But think about the reaction
and then we will talk
about where you last met her.
-
When glycolysis is complete,
of each glucose molecule
we get two pyruvate molecules.
So at the first step
each of these molecules loses its carboxyl group.
This process is helped
of pyruvate decarboxylase.
The name of the enzyme means that it is
cleaves the carboxyl group.
You see that when we remove the carboxyl group,
it consists of one carbon and two oxygen atoms,
I will not show the detailed mechanism,
but it will
carbon dioxide,
who will separate himself.
And the rest,
I will not again show the mechanism,
but the rest will be acetaldehyde,
you can pay attention to some of the atoms that build it.
Acetaldehyde, I find it hard to pronounce it.
In the next step
the acetaldehyde may be reduced.
We can assume,
that it is reduced by NADN
and converted to ethanol.
The mechanism is similar
to the one we saw in lactic acid fermentation,
where from pyruvate we received lactic acid.
However, acetaldehyde is converted to ethanol.
This here
is reduced.
Reduced,
receives a hydride anion.
We can say,
that he gains a hydride anion,
at the reduction pathway of this molecule,
NON is oxidized.
This is oxidized.
The main purpose of all this process,
the reason for it to happen
is the oxidation of NADH,
to get a new NAD + for the next glycolysis.
As I mentioned in the video about lactic acid,
this is a little unfortunate,
because pyruvate also contains energy.
If we had oxygen,
we could have cellular breathing
and the Krebs cycle,
citric acid cycle
and get energy from it.
The oxidation process of NADN
in theory can create more energy.
But with none of the fermentation types,
this does not happen.
Nor does it happen with alcohol,
nor in lactic acid fermentation.
However, these are processes,
which have always been very useful for human civilization.
When talking about alcohol fermentation,
the most famous
a participant in it is here.
These are yeasts.
They are classified as mushrooms.
This is a yeast cell.
Its diameter is several micrometres,
but it may vary.
Different types of yeast are used
the production of bread and wine,
or in the production of alcohol.
Also in beer production.
Yeast
digest sugar by glycolysis
and then alcoholic fermentation takes place there.
And what makes the bread roll up is this step here.
When the carboxyl group is removed from the pyruvate,
this is assisted by pyruvate decarboxylase,
carbon dioxide is released,
who makes the bread fluffy.
Carbon dioxide creates bubbles in the dough
and gives it a pleasant taste and texture.
In addition, ethanol is also produced.
An interesting fact is that
-
in bread usually
there are traces of alcohol.
Bread contains
traces of ethanol,
because to make it
yeast is used.
To make it soft and swell,
glycolysis occurs in yeast
and the alcoholic fermentation in which they are produced
ethanol and carbon dioxide.
So the bread swells,
but there are traces of ethanol in it.
But if we talk about wine,
the goal is to produce ethanol,
which we see as traditional drinking alcohol.
So yeasts play a very important role in people's societies.